فقط تشير لاننا نتابع الان لقطات مباشره
من الموقع الذي تم فيه هذا الهجوم اذا
تقول بان نتنياهو امر باستدعاء جنود
الاحتياط والمزيد من التعبئه
وهذا اجراء صدقه وان اتخذ في حالات فقط
عندما تكون يكون هناك ظرف امني كبير يتم
تجديد كتائب احتياط من حرس الخدود ومن
الجيش
الاسرائيلي
ولكن بطبيعه الحال معروف بان هذه العمليات
محمد تسمى العمليات الفرديه يقوم شخص
بمفرده بتنفيذ عمليه كهذه لا توجد معلومات
مستخباراتيه وبالتالي يعني تعداد القوات
لا يؤثر في نهايه المطاف في مثل هذه
العمليات لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات